bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 78 weekend
beaucoup d'invité pour m'accompagner
pendant cette émission nous allons
parler de magie de la Nuit des musées
mais tout d'abord de l'initiative parole
de jardinier avec vous Syvie bonjour
bonjour Alors parole des jardiners c'est
du 17 mai au 1er juin quel est l'esprit
de cette nouvelle édition 3e du nom
alors cette année on a une thématique
particulière qui est les fleurs dans
tous leurs états vaste sujet et dans
lesquels vont s'inscrire toutes les
animations puisque il y en a il y a 48
participants 105 animations qui
s'incrivent dans le les chiffres non ça
va s'arrêter là parce que c'est pas le
plus fun c'est pas le plus fun le fun
c'est de savoir ce qu'il y a à faire la
plupart des animations sont gratuites
c'est important de le dire aussi vousz
détailloui il y a 87 animations
gratuites sur les sur les 105 ce qui
n'est quand même pas négligeable ce qui
n'est quand même pas négligeable alors
on va commencer par parler pour parler
certaines on va pas tout détailler
peut-être parler c'est clair bah ça
ferait il nous faudrait plus de plus de
temps que ça on va d'abord aller à
rambouiller pour une opération qui
s'appelle un jardin peut en cacher un
autre oui alors là l'idée c'est de
découvrir un peu tous les types de
jardins de grands jardins qui existent à
Rambouillet avec les jardiniers de la
ville et aussi avec les jardiniers du
domaine national de Rambouillet donc on
va au jardin la mode qui est un un
jardin d'un château on va au au jardin
du de Grousset qui est un jardin nature
et puis on va ensuite pour terminer euh
donc au domaine national de Rambouillet
tout en passant par les ces municipales
qui regorgent de plantes et de fleurs
tout ça accompagné de spécialistes bien
sûr et ce samedi il y a un grand marché
horticole voilà aussi en plus voilà à
découvrir euh Saint-Germain en lait avec
vous Syvie on va faire tout les
département B alors on voyage à la
vitesse éclair pou on quit rambouillant
on va du côté de Saint-Germain en laai
au domain nation alorsint-germain en
Laet au domaine national de
Saint-Germain en laai c'est la clôture
de notre événement qui figure aussi dans
le cadre de la manifestation nationale
rendez-vous au jardin et ça s'appelle
jardin de spectacle euh donc c'est tout
un tas d'animation hein et donc il y en
a énormément et particulièrement
beaucoup d'animations pour les enfants
puisque le thème de rendez-vous au
jardin manifestation nationale c'est
c'est ce sont les enfants donc il y a
des des manèges spécifiques il y a des
petits lutins ce qu'on voit là à l'écran
ce sont des des lutins habillés en vert
sur des ressorts avec leur reinees qui
les suit et dans son traîneau il y a
tout un tas de choses extraordinaires
c'est Noël au mois de mai c'est ça c'est
donc plein d'animations pour les enfants
et donc il y en a pour tous les goûts il
y a aussi des ateliers cuisiner les
fleurs faire son parfum enfin il y en a
pour tous les goûts et tout le monde
pourra profiter ce 1er juin du domaine
national de de Saint-Germain qui est
magnifique donc rouill Saint-Germain je
juste pr pris que c'est gratuit
absolument animations gratuit on va du
côté de l'arboretum de Chèvreloup ça
c'est pour ce dimanche alors ce dimanche
à l'Arboretum faut se rappeler quand
même ce que c'est que l'arboretum c'est
un un espace où il y a 2500 espèces
d'arbres qui viennent du monde entier et
là on vous propose de faire du rampotage
d'apprendre à à jardiner et bah vraiment
on devient un véritable élève et on vous
encadre dans ce cadre merveilleux tout à
fait euh et c'est un tarif de alors je
donne les tarifs j' donner les tarifs
non c'est pas bien cher c'est 4 € pour
les adultes et 2 € pour les enfants au
jardin il y a un jardin qui s'appelle le
jardin des jardinier de France du valde
Seine moi je le connais pas et c'est à
lî laomôe et c'est à mon la jolie voà et
c'est le 24 mai qui ça et alors déjà
l'île lomô en tant que telle c'est
magnifique he c'est une île au milieu de
la scène on a déjà l'impression d'être
en vacances et les
jardiniers du de France vous accueillent
et vous apprennent à cultiver un potager
donc on est on arrive on y connaît rien
et on vous propose de cultiver son
potager comme si c'était le le sien et
puis on peut après aussi tous
piqueniquer ensemble avec un moment très
très convivial dans cet espace
magnifique on a l'impression d'être en
vacances alors c'est le 24 mai du côté
de monre la jolie le 25 mai le lendemain
on va aller au parc de la prévenderie à
coignère non plus je connais pas ben
voilà c'est pas très loin de 50 an alors
le parc de la
prévenderie il est il est ouvert tout le
temps mais il réalise des des animations
spécifiquement pour nous et c'est les
jardiniers de la ville de coignère qui
proposent ces animations il y en a pour
les enfants où on propose de faire des
petits espaces fleuris avec des petites
plantes qu'on cultive qu'on apprend à
cultiver soi-même pour les enfants et
puis des scènes Fury spécifiques que que
les les adultes peuvent réaliser et ça
c'est gratuit également comme l'Î au
moine le Potager du Roi alors le Potager
du Roi quand même voilà on a déjà parlé
on en a déjà parlé la la fois dernière
effectivement dans la boutique gourmande
mais là c'est pas du tout le même
principe c'est qu'on visite le
potager avec un une thématique un peu
spécifique qui est les plantes
aromatiques et puis les fleurs
comestibles donc on va découvrir le
potager toujours avec ses légumes
anciens et et tout ce qu'il ce dont il
regorge habituellement mais sur cette
thématique spécifique puisque rappelons
que le thème de notre manifestation ce
sont les fleurs dans tous leurs états
donc état com aussi tout à fait c'est
aussi payant c'est 4,50 € pour les
adultes je leuris donné les tarifs et
dernière manifestation je rappelle qu'il
y a 48 parcs qui participent à par de J
donc on va pas détailler tous les parcs
on va finir sur on va dire les les les
propositions en tout cas du de Syvie
voilà le choix de Sylvie sur le jardin
de Cocagne à Manille et am voilà alors
c'est pas très loin d'ici là c'est un
jardin nature et et donc on ramasse tous
les fruits et les légumes à la main on
est vraiment dans un état d'esprit
développement durable donc on va vous
donner des trucs aussi des petites des
petites astuces pour savoir exactement
comment jardiner et puis il y a des des
petits ateliers spécifiques qui sont
proposés sur la poésie dans les jardins
et puis on découvre aussi les abeilles
puisque il y a il y a des abeilles et
des et des ruches dans ce dans ce parc
donc c'est assez varié on peut y passer
un bon moment ensemble ble en toute
convivialité oui et c'est en plus une
très belle initiative sociale le jardin
de Cocagne donc voilà ça note à rien
donc parole de jardinier je le rappelle
c'est du 17 mai au 1er juin il y a 48
parcs et jardins qui ouvrent leurs
portes et qui proposent les activités
donc on a vu des parcs publ il y a aussi
des des particuliers aussi qui
participent oui oui oui oui il y a aussi
des particuliers qui qui participent à
l'événement on a le Clo paradenia
safrané qui est à Roset dans le nord du
département c'est un couple de retraité
qui sont des passionnés de jardin qui
ont des roses de tout les de toutes les
espèces possibles anciennes plus plus
traditionnel enfin bon il y a énormément
de choses faut pas oublier qu'on peut
demander le programme ou aller sur
le sur le blog puisque c'est un blog et
pas un site internet où vous pouvez même
déposer vos commentaires et on y répond
bien sûr on peut donner au coup de cœur
vous a plu et tout donc c'est très
interactif si vous êtes ferru de fleurs
et de jardin c'est vraiment la période
en ce moment et en plus le weekend
s'annonce très beau donc c'est vraiment
d'aller
voir les éclosions dans les jardins à
partir donc de ce samedi jusqu'au 1er
juin merci beaucoup Sylvie d'être venue
dans cette suite weekend allez une autre
idée de sortie samedi à la base de
loisir de 50 ans niveline la base de
loisir accueille le club jeune théâtre
et poésie pour un événement des plus
original sur le thème des oiseaux ils
déclameront leur poésie dans les arbres
et sur l'eau et oui Aurélia debici pour
les
explications face à l'oiseau tu viens
t'asseoir puis grande nuit le fleuve est
long dans l'œil des ronds qui tourner
ront le firmament danse en étoile sur le
halage certains
soirs tel des oiseaux d'eau nichés dans
les arbres les jeunes vcinois du club de
théâtre et poésie investissent la base
de loisir pour y faire entendre les
textes de Jacques moulin à vol d'oiseau
les jeunes comédiens répètent en vue du
spectacle qui sera donné samedi 17 mai à
20h pour la 2e édition les poèmes seront
déclamés au-dessus du public sur un arbr
perché et d'autres nouveautés cette
année seront entendues depuis les temps
de la base nautique ça rend ludique la
poésie qui est
difficilement qui est jugé un peu
ringarde par les par les jeunes donc
tout de suite l'année dernière déjà dans
les arbres ça leur avait donné un petit
une petite motivation en plus pour pour
dire la poésie et puis c'est plus
intéressant en plus cette année on a une
musicienneis Catala qui qui travaille
avec nous donc c'est c'est plus
intéressant pour eux et pour tout le
un événement original organisé par la
Maison de la poésie à guillancour et le
théâtre du sable qui sans nul doute
confirme l'implication des jeunes pour
la poésie ce qui est bien c'est que ça
donne justement la beauté du texte mais
il y a une autre beauté et du coup
forcément je trouve ça un peu mieux que
une approche classique parce que ça
présente tous les avantages d'une
approche classique plusah les avantages
d'une autre approche sans présenter
vraiment d'inconvénient dans l'alliance
des deux faut vraiment venir parce que
je trouve ça magnifique parce que y a y
a plein de phases de l'art différentes
donc la beauté du lieu la beauté de la
musique qui est joué avec ainsi que la
beauté des textes et donc l'alliance des
trois rev une dimension
magnifique allez on poursuit ce 7 h
weekend on va parler dans quelques
instants de la Nuit des musées qui a
lieu ce samedi 17 mai et puis également
un festival de magie qui se déroule à
voisin le Bretonneux autour de la table
pour en parler Olivier gazon bonsoir
vous ê responsable communication de
l'association 78 tours les 78 tours
exactement8 tours le nom est vraiment
bien bien trouvé fabriceur bonsoir vous
êtes vous-même magicien et vous allez
participer à ce festival de magie al
c'est un festival de magie qui démarre
vendredi samedi dimanche qui dure 3
jours à voisin le le Bretonneux d'abord
est-ce que c'est un festival ouvert à
tous petit comme grand par qu'on dit
c'est plutôt pour les petits la magie
mais on est grand et curieux on aime
bien aussi non il faut il faut quitter
ces idées préconçues comme quoi la magie
c'est pour les enfants puisqu'elle plaît
également énor ment au grand et ça vous
pouvez le voir également par les la
programmation du festival puisque dans
dans ce festival on a beaucoup de
magiciens qui ont des Talents vraiment
très différents des machins qui sont
plus qui ont des spectacles plus adaptés
pour des enfants justement de jeunes
enfants et d'autres d'autres spectacles
comme par exemple le spectacle de
Fabrice au de cœur qui est plus desstiné
à un public au-dessus de 10 ans d'accord
c'est c'est juste pour préciser c'est
c'est un festival qui a lieu au sein de
l'espace de Coville dans la de l'espace
de cille et il y a deux lieux deux trois
lieux ex alors en fait l'espace de
Coville est ouvert au public pour le
festival et gratuit donc le public peut
se rendre directement sur le site et et
en même temps profiter des animations
qu'on aura dans l'espace de Coville il y
aura des stands d'initiation à la magie
on aura des stands de sculpture sur
ballon qui seront offerts aux enfants et
au grands on aura une boutique également
de magie on aura de la restauration on
aura plein de surprises on aura des
tombolin ENF on aura plein de choses
plein plein d'animations et dans la
salle de la tour des spectacles des
spectacles qui eux seront payants mais
en moyenne entre 3 et 12 € le spectacle
ce qui est beaucoup moins cher que le
tarif que vous pourriez payer si vous
allez voir ces artistes sur la sur Paris
donc quel type de de magicien vous avez
commencé à en parler un petit peu mais
la magie on l'impression que c'est le
tour de cartte mais il y a pas que le
tour de carte heureusement
heureusementus dis ça mais sur votre
votre chemise il y a que des cartes oui
ça c'est fait exprès c'est pour c'est
pour vous rassurer pour me dire ah je
suis bien magicien non mais je je fais
très peu de tours de cartes voilà dans
mon spectacle j'en fais un parce que les
gens le demandent mais mais sinon non
non non je je fais pas de de tour de cte
mais non il il y a tour il dans la magie
il y a les mentalistes aussi on a un
super spectacle le soir de de mentaliste
c'est quand le spectacle de mentaliste
pour ce qui intéressent c'est le samedi
soir c'est ça exactement avec le
spectacle l'œil de Cassandre de pourang
voilà donc donc voilà donc là c'est
mentaliste et puis après voilà il y a
des tours de cord des tours de foulard
et tour avec des animaux il voilà la
magie c'est pas également y a beaucoup
de CH Oui oui oui oui ouive vous
qu'est-ce que vous faites Fabrice alors
alors moi c'est basé un peu sur l'humour
c'est c'est vraim c'est avec des jeunes
mots
entre un peu un mélange de Raymond de
vos et puis et puis de la magie donc
donc voilà donc c'est vraiment tourné
c'est pour ça que mon spectacle il y a
rien de vulgaire mais qui est
déconseillé au moins de 10 ans parce
qu'ils vont pas comprendre les jeux de
mots après donc voilà c'est c'est c'est
plutôt pour adultes c'est plutôt pour
adultes voilà je m'enf un clou grand
comme ça dans le nez avec un marteau
aussi voilà il y a du mentaliste alors
le mentaliste forcément c'est pas aussi
heureusement que vous êtes pas venu
faire une démonstration parce que dans
le nez non non non non non non non par
contre je peux juste vous montrer le
clou que c'est voilà c'est ah oui
d'accord c'est un vrai clou c'est un
vrai cl c'est un vrai clou donc voilà on
n pas le temps je sa frapp et puis voilà
donc j'ai des leçons de secours aussi de
secouriste si vous voulez après si vous
avez un malaise il y a pas de souci je
peux vous
souourir don voilà non non non mais
c'est un spectacle voilà de de comment
dire avec beaucoup d'humour voilà c'est
c'est entre le le le one man et puis
puis la magie voilà pour moi pour 125 kg
de magiciens présents à l'occasion de
ces TR jours de festival alors au total
nous aurons en comptant les magiciens
qui qui interviennent extérieur de
l'association et les magiciens de
l'association on sera à peu près une
trentaine de magiciens 30 magiciens
comment comment on fait un choix comme
ça il y a pltor de magiciens c'est un
choix très très dur c'est un so très dur
non on a essayé justement de laisser de
laisser une place pour tous les
magiciens déjà de l'association aussi
bien sur les spectacles qui onuront lieu
à la salle de la tour mais également sur
des des des des spectacles de close-up
que l'on fera également euh donc non
tout le monde a re à trouver sa place
puis après il y en a d'autres aussi qui
n'ont pas forcément envie de de faire
des tours au grand public qui préfèrent
faire des tours bah à leurs amis ou à
leur famille donc mais bon on a trouvé
une place vraiment pour tout le monde
parce qu'on a l'impression quand même
que le monde de la magie a beaucoup
évolué depuis ah bah je sais pas non je
disais évolué parce que ça a changé
qu'est-ce qui plaît le plus
aujourd'hui un peu tout ou ouais un peu
tout je pense que c'est non les gens
commencent à regarder plus les
personnalités des magiciens c'est-à-dire
que les tours voilà ils ont pas ils ont
certains ont évolué comme comme par
exemple Magic flash qui fait avec des
lumières tout ça donc donc ça ça
forcément c'est moderne mais mais sinon
je pense c'est la personnalité des voilà
et puis puis on est parti un peu dans d'
une manière un peu anglo-saxon
c'està-dire que si on dit un Américain
on est magicien tout de suite ah oui
fais-nous un tour voilà qui ils ont
n'importe quel âge alors que en France
pendant des années c'était ah c'est bien
pour les enfants donc voilà alors que là
on commence justement à se dire la magie
c'est pour tout le monde et
effectivement c'est voilà spectacle pour
enfant c'est pour enfant ça c'est sûr
mais spectacle pour adultes voilà c'est
pour tout le monde et aussi c'est
peut-être devenu un vrai spectacle
aujourd'hui la exactement exactement il
y a vraiment des recherches un peu comme
comme aussi les les dessins animés de de
Walt Disney où il y a quelques années il
cblit vraiment que pour enfant mais
maintenant ça c'est toujours un film
pour enfants mais avec des références
pour adultes et ce qui fait que toute la
famille vont voir le spectacle avec
plaisir alors quand vous dites c'est une
histoire de personnalité il faut que les
gens accrochent sur la personnalité du
magicien par ex fa quand vous arrivez
sur scène c'est quoi c'est une question
de charisme faut tout de suite comment
on
captive je le fais bien mais comment
comment on captive comme ça moi je
commence à parler de mon poids donc déjà
ça j'ai pas dit le nom de votre je me
suis pas
permis5 voà 125 kg de délire donc voilà
donc donc je commence en disant voilà
que ça soit bien clair entre nous même
si c'est je fais 125 kg je suis pas gros
ok je suis pas gros je suis juste un
petit peu et comme pu il est gentil et
ben il dit enveloppé et là je dis non je
suis obèse donc bah ouais je devrais
faire 80 85 kg j'en fais 125 vous
appelez ça comment légère surcharge
pondérale voilà donc je commence à à
faire de l'humour avec rien que mon
poids voilà avant de faire de la magie
et puis après je parle de mon premier
tour de magie et puis et puis après
après on enchaîne et puis voilà bon un
dernier mot Olivier oui parce que jeis
pas faire de jalou au niveau des des
autres artistes quand même vous ave là
non non ou il il y a le site internet
qui qui s'affiche on peut voir tout ça
non je voudrais simplement un dernier
mot rapideè on va passer là la parole à
Lucie sauvage pour parler de la Nuit des
musées mais jeis un dernier mot sur
l'association 78 tours donc parce que
vous dites qu'il y a 30 magiciens
pendant ce festival dont les magiciens
de l'association c'est-à-dire que si on
est passionné par la magie on peut vous
retrouver quand tous les jeudis alors
c'est tous les jeudis on a une réunion
qui qui se déroule tous les jeudis à
l'espace de Coville à 20h30 donc pour
même plus d'information si le site est
inscrit parfait les gens peuvent aller
voir sur le site internet pour voir un
petit peu comment ça se passe au niveau
des au niveau des réunions mais bon
c'est ouvert à tout le monde il y a pas
de test d'entrée si on aime la magie
qu'on veut partager et ben on vient n
voir le jeudi je dis jeudi le site c'est
ww.les78our.comors très important
également pour réserver sa place pour
les spectacles car on a eu beaucoup de
réservations et j'invite les gens qui
veulent venir ce weekend pour voir un
spectacle de réserver sur Internet c'est
important car la salle de la tour est
assez petite et il y a déjà des
spectacles complet exactement c'est pour
ça qu'on vaer rejouer les artistes sont
super sympas avec nous ils sont pr à
rejouer deux fois leur num alors le
festival de magie de voisin de
Bretonneux c'est donc 16 17 18 mai et si
vous voulez réserver aller sur le site
de l'association Les
wwles78tours.com tout simplement merci à
vous deux d'être passé reste encore
quelques instants allez on va parler de
la Nuit des Musées grosse concurrence ce
weekend parce que c'est la 10e édition
des Nuits européennes des musées on
accueille Lucy sauvage bonsoir vous êtes
responsable de l'action culturel au
musée de la ville et le musée de la
ville ne pouvait pas manquer la Nuit des
Musées évidemment autour d'une
thématique des cultures urbaines donc
c'est plutôt étonnant expliqueznous un
petit peu ce qu'on va découvrir pendant
ce samedi à partir de 19h alors les
cultures urbaines d'abord parce qu'on a
fait une exposition qui s'appelle street
culture Sky autour des cultures urbaines
dans le cadre des 30 ans du hiphop à 5S
en Yveline et donc une nuit des musées
autour du hiph-op et des cultures
urbaines plus largement où on pourra
découvrir à la fois on pourra s'initier
à des pratiques hiphop comme de la danse
on a trois ateliers de danse le street
art avec deux propositions de street
installation et de pochoir et puis du
graphe aussi atelier d'initation au grap
il y aura également des performances
d'artistes euh pareil graffeur danseur
également un Flash Mob où tout le monde
pourra participer on va rentrer en
détail j'ai pas demandé où ça situit
c'est devant le le musée de la
ville du musée de la ville tout
simplement c'est gratuit c'est aussi
important grat c'est accessible euh il y
a plusieurs ateliers avec des noms
bizarres pouri pour moi c'est un peu
bizarre le shilling outout c'est quoi
alors shilling outout c'est le nom de la
série d'un artiste qui s'appelle
littleka qui est un plasticien qui
travaille autour de l'univers du hiphop
et de la culture matérielle du hiphop et
surtout qui fait des des photographies
de personnages en P de polymère qu'il
appelle des chillings et ça veut dire
tout chill out c'est traîné dans la rue
et c'est quelque chose qui est récurrent
dans le le Hipop déjà de ce fait d'être
une culture de rue de choses qui se
passent dans la rue et de gens qui
arpentent la ville qui qui parcourent
l'espace urbain donc cette ce nom
chilling out est en référence à cette
série de de street installation de
littleka d'accord donc on pourra faire
concrètement quoi comme animation pour
alors concrètement littleka vient lors
de cette nu des musées et initiera les
gens à créer eux même modeler des
sculptures en P de polymère qu'ils iront
installer à sa manière dans l'espace
public et prendre en photo c'est le
principe desestit installation qu'on met
dans l'espace public et qu'on offre à
l'espace public qu'on laisse ensuite et
chacun peut s'approprier le l'œuvre
d'accord vous avez parlé d'une flash mob
je sais pas si on dit un Flash Mob ou
une FL on dit un Flash Mob en général
mais il y a pas vraiment de genre
puisque c'est un mot anglais en français
une une foule écla une mobilisation
éclaair voilà pour la Mobilis
ça fa super moderne ça sera entre 21h et
21h30 rappelez-nous le principe et puis
si les gens ont rien préparer est-ce
qu'on doit déjà préparer quelque chose
est-ce qu'on doit télécharger quelque
chose pour il a rien à préparer et c'est
pour ça que c'est pas exactement un
Flash Mob tel que le commun du mortel
l'entend un flash mom normalement c'est
préparé à l'avance les gens se
réunissent font une chorégraphie puis se
dispersent là on a rien à apprendre à
l'avance on apprendra la chorégraphie
sur place donc même si on est nul en
danse on pe quand même est absolument
nul et conna rien un souci on a des gens
qui vont vous initier au pas hiphop à
différents styles Hipop et ensuite la
chorégraphie sera fait avec tous les
gens qui veulent y participer mais c'est
vraiment ouvert à tous et n'importe qui
peut s'essayer à la la chorégraphie du
flash m il y a un concert de rap à 21h30
oui avec des artistes qui nous ont qui
ont participé à l'exposition street
culture Sky également qui feront des des
démonstrations de rap de leurs morceaux
et à 22h un battle de Hipop un battle hi
on peut rapper pareil le principe du
Battle le principe du Battle donc défi
on disait un défi dans les années 80
pareil pour le la francisation du terme
un battle c'est une rencontre entre
danseurs qui se qui s'affronte en étant
le plus performant possible et ça se
juge vraiment à la performance celui qui
gagne et celui qui a fait la plus belle
démonstration de danse dans son style il
y aura différents styles qui seront
représentés demain soir voilà et à 22h30
alors il av un lchet de ballon rouge ça
c'est drôle ça un lchet de ballon rouge
qui est en hommage c'est pas voilà c'est
ça c'est pas un Odin voilà à l'artiste
street artiste bsy qui est un street
artiste internationalement connu et
reconnu et qui a fait une un dessin
notamment très connu sur les murs enfin
sur deux murs de de Londres qui est une
petite fille au ballon rouge et il y a
pas très longtemps il a appelé plusieurs
villes à faire des lâchés de ballon
notamment lien avec la Syrie et donc ce
lâché de ballon est en hommage à cet
artiste là tout à fait donc lâchet de
ballon rouge à 22h30 et beaucoup
d'animations on l'a bien compris à
partir de 19h des démonstrations et des
ateliers qu'on on peut suivre même si on
n'est pas forcément doué en en danse ou
en art plastique en tout cas ça vaut le
coup de venir et puis a l'exposition
street culture cquentin ou Sky je sais
pas comment on dit on peut dire comme on
veut comme on veut tout elle est ouverte
elle est ouverte jusqu'à 22h30 ouverture
exceptionnelle de de l'exposition et je
rappelle que tout ça est gratuit gratuit
access vous avez déjà des il y a des
réservations c'est c'est pas sur
réservation c'est vraiment en accès
libre il y a des ateliers pour lesquels
il y a des inscriptions mais c'est sur
place le jour même d'accord donc si vous
aimez les cultures urbaines ou en tout
cas si vous êtes curieux vous voulez
découvrir à l'occasion de la Nuit des
Musées rendez-vous donc à partir de 19h
devant le musée de la ville sur le
parvie à côté de la médiathèque du du
canal à Montini si vous êtes un danseur
et que vous voulez participer au battle
c'est tout à fait possible aussi c'est
sur inscription sur place alors Fabrice
il est
il oui de la tête vous êtes danseur
Fabrice non j'ai parce que parce que
j'ai fait j'ai fait un spectacle qui
s'appelit memory ù c'était
intergénérationnel et je danser voilà
c'est pour ça ah bon alors en tout cas
pour les pour les les danseurs les vrais
danseurs de hiphop rendez-vous pour le
pour le battle ce sera donc à partir de
22h devant le musée de la ville merci
luci aussi d'être venu et ben merci à
vous trois allez on va terminer ce 7
weekend avec le traditionnel agenda
alors il y a bien sûr évidemment
beaucoup de dates à retenir vous en
doutez autour de cette 10e nuit et des
musées il y a de la concurrence he dans
le département vous savez on va
commencer par le château de Versailles
l'entrée est gratuite entre 19h30 et 1h
du matin il sera possible de voir les
grands appartements du roi et de la
reine visiter la galerie des glaces ou
encore les appartements des filles de
Louis XV attention la dernière entrée
autorisée est à minuit 30 allez plus
proche de nous à manilamo toujours dans
la cl de la Nuit des Musées le musée
donc national de Port Royal accueille
vous propose une visite guidée à partir
de 19h suivi d'un concert à 20h de
violon et de piano autour des œuvres de
procofief Schubert ou Bram et l'entrée
est gratuite allez on va quitter la nuit
des musée il y a d'autres animations
aussi pendant le weekend d'abord ce
buffet spectacle qui est proposé samedi
soir la salle goguin de Montini au
profit de l'Association Française pour
la recherche sur la trisomie 21 et puis
euh la ville de plaisir qui lance qui
vous fait un peu de concurrence aussi
euh qui lance le premier festival des
cultures urbaines qui a lieu du 16 au 25
mai euh donc ce weekend il y aura des
concerts de régé des spectacles pour les
enfants et des expositions de graffiti
pour démarrer ce programme de 10 jours
et à plaisir toujours si vous aimez les
jeux de société je vous conseille
d'aimer les jeux de société parce que
c'est très F est très amusant et bien le
samedi 17 mai à partir de 15h au centre
social Flora Christan ce sera donc le
paradis des jeux de société et puis une
dernière opération très vite c'est à la
base de loisirs de Moisson les jeunes du
LC qui organisent un trophée de golf
caritatif cette émission est terminée
merci d' l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite
un excellent
weekend